ready get set
go
bmw is celebrating the 40th anniversary
of its popular 3 series
since their debut in 1975 these cars
have developed a reputation as solid
compacts that are fun to drive
there have been six generations of three
series cars and each has been built on
the success of its predecessor the third
generation featured a completely new
design a distinctive wedge shape
the wheelbase was extended by 13
centimeters making for a more spacious
passenger compartment and bmw kept
designing new 3-series body styles
including sedans convertibles coupes
touring cars and the motorsport version
the fifth generation came out with an
impressive array of innovations in the
engine and chassis and it was more
comfortable
the latest three series generation will
pick up right where the fifth generation
left off
automotive journalist hans joachim regg
says bmw has sharpened its focus and all
the right places for the sixth
generation the engines are more
efficient the suspension's improved and
all-round full led lights have been
added
the sixth generation bmws may not
inspire oohs and oz but then they
weren't intended to at night the
optional full led headlights really
stand out but optically the design is
more reserved and that's not a bad thing
the three series have always been icons
of style
we took a top of the line 340i out for a
test drive it's powered by a 240
kilowatt twin power turbo inline six
cylinder engine
bmw didn't change much and the design of
the passenger compartment the chrome
accents are still there lending as ever
a quiet grace to the interior
points out that the advantages of the
340 ice high performance 326 horsepower
engine and adds that this engine runs a
lot more efficiently than previous
designs
fuel consumption can easily hit nine
liters per 100 kilometers
can this
auto liter baby
it's not easy to combine that kind of
horsepower with fuel efficiency but bmw
was up to the task bmw itself rates fuel
consumption at 6.8 liters the new 340i
has also cut co2 emissions by 11
over the previous generation
says he really likes the improvements
bmw has made to the suspension
that makes for an especially smooth and
comfortable ride but it also has good
stability and traction going into curves
about 25 of all new bmw sold are three
series models there's a wide variety of
engine options to choose from four
gasoline and seven diesel powered models
ranging from 85 to 240 kilowatts these
cars range from 30 200 to just under 57
000 euros in germany
really likes the way the bmw has
re-engineered the 3-series he's
particularly impressed with a wide range
of engine options from the 3-cylinder
5.1 liter to the 240 kilowatt 340i
enis presents volvo's v40 hatchback she
says it's like a premium version of the
vw golf enos is going to find out
whether the v40s design and top of the
line features will set it apart from its
compact competitors
the v40 sleek design is distinctive that
includes the v-shaped hood which gives
the car a look that's at once bold and
elegant
the rear of the car features a
streamlined combination of glass and
metal that surrounds the six-sided
tailgate
other attractive features include the
angular tail lights that rise to the
c-pillar
points out that the v-40 is powered by
the all-new drive e powertrain which
includes the 2-liter engine there's a
whole range of units to choose from
diesel and gasoline and various
performance options
there are three diesel and three
gasoline engine options
we're testing the middle diesel model
which comes with a manual 6-speed
gearbox all models though are also
available with automatic transmission
the short throw shifter has a sports car
feel to it and the suspension is
comfortably tuned
the v40 goes from zero to 100 kilometers
per hour in 8.4 seconds and has a top
speed of 210
the german price for the car we're
testing today is just under 30 000 euros
add on a few accessories and it'll cost
a few grand more
highlights volvo's use of fuel efficient
engines the d3 model that we're testing
generates 110 kilowatts and uses just
3.8 liters of fuel to cover 100
kilometers those numbers show up on the
dynometer
but with a torque rating of 320 newton
meters it's so much fun to accelerate
quickly that people will have a tough
time hitting 3.8 liters
the v40s interior looks very
scandinavian it's functional but with
the occasional touch of extravagance
like the floating center console
among the optional extras is a leather
driver's seat complete with a seat
adjustment memory function
ena says the v40 has three main
equipment options today we're using the
second one it's got a great mix of
colors materials and surfaces she also
likes the simple design of the buttons
it's all very well designed and easy to
operate
the v40s back bench has plenty of room
there are some smart looking cup holders
and you can take out the central armrest
so you'll have even more space to
stretch out
the rear seats are split and can be
folded down to create plenty of cargo
space and when you fold them back up
you'll find hooks that you can hang your
shopping bags on
innis really likes the design of the
volvo v40 and really enjoy driving it in
germany the basic model costs under 24
000 euros what's more you can add a
large number of extra safety features it
comes standard equipped with the city
safety assistant and an external airbag
that stretches across the front of the
car to protect pedestrians
volvo has a solid reputation for
building safe cars and the v40 continues
that tradition we think the improvements
that volvo has made to this model will
help put it out front of the competition
and sets a new standard for pedestrian
protection
the new mx-5 will be hitting the road in
september mazda has managed to cut its
weight by 100 kilos the legendary
roadster is powered by a choice of
engines with 96 or 118 kilowatts of
output prices in germany started 23 000
euros going up to 30 grand for that top
of the line edition
the audi s8 is now also available as a
performance edition called plus 445
kilowatts catapult the car from zero to
100 kilometers per hour in 3.8 seconds
the dynamic package standard fitted in
germany pushes the top speed to 305
kilometers per hour it'll go on sale in
germany for 145 000 euros
was an automotive legend when it was
brought back in 2007 following the
revival of other retro legends like the
beetle and the mini all now fixtures on
europe's roads
car tester android zimmerman describes
the new fiat 500 as the quintessential
success story with some one and a half
million sales it's the second biggest
seller among sub-compact city cars in
germany and the number one seller in all
of europe now fiat has thoroughly
upgraded it
about half of the fiat 500's buyers opt
for the basic engine combined with a top
of the line equipment option known as
the lounge at 115 grams of co2 per
kilometer the 1.2 liter engine still
emits more co2 than the stronger twin
air engines
in germany the starting price for our
test car is 14 650 euros with no extras
andre likes the fiat 500 compared to
other sub compacts because of the
well-balanced steering he says it's
noticeably tighter but the city button
loosens it up a bit without it becoming
ridiculously squishy
easy maneuverability is one of the main
selling points of subcompacts as they're
generally used for driving around town
but what's really and truly new about
the new fiat 500.
ava wagner of fiat says that they had to
be very very careful with such an icon
the risk of somehow ruining the design
was enormous so they concentrated on
stressing precisely those elements that
make the 500 one of a kind normal
one of those features is nicknamed the
mustache the chrome that runs between
the fiat logo and the headlights
the led daytime running lights are
designed in the style of the 500s logo
a choice of no less than 10 different
light alloy rims helps to personalize
the new 500 one of the most conspicuous
changes is the tail light inlay in the
body's paint
the sat nav's display is a bit on the
small side but it has options for
example enabling the driver to stream
music from the internet in conjunction
with a smartphone
and state-of-the-art instruments are
presented in the classic look
the full-size lockable glove compartment
is also new
andre likes the fiat 500's retro chic
interior but he doesn't like the seat
height he's quite tall so even at the
lowest setting he feels a little
squeezed in shorter people could go for
it though
andre doesn't see many real changes to
the new fiat 500 but the touch-ups to
the exterior do make it more stylish the
unique selling point among sub-compacts
is yet to come a diesel engine
racing drivers often call the spa
francorchamp the roller coaster in the
ardennes before hosting the belgian
grand prix later this month the track
tested driver's endurance at the annual
total 24 hours of spa race it was a
special occasion for bmw the final
competition for the z4 gt3 plus the
50-year anniversary pascal x and gerard
langlois victory bmw's first win here
bmw started with a quite new family of
cars and we had very much pleasure in
racing the 700 bmw that was the reason
the first love the first reason to love
bmw
bmw has racked up a total of 21
victories on this highly demanding track
this time though weather conditions were
anything but helpful
driver lucas lure says spa is one of the
last old-school tracks
english separates the men from the boys
the royal motorsport team faced a rather
particular challenge joining dtm winner
bruno spangler and former formula one
driver timo glock was alessandro zanari
who lost both legs in a crash in 2001
of course it's quite difficult to put
all the three together especially
because of the for alex
but i think
together with bmw we managed very well
and
till now i think everybody has done a
good job there's nothing more we could
do to show up better prepare and
i'm very very pleased and excited and
proud to be part of this team
we have fantastic engineers and
mechanics it's a pleasure to be together
with alex and timo alex has taught me a
lot about racing which is why it's so
much fun here
we want to find our pace right at the
start and we'll see how we fare at night
and through the whole 24 hours
the driver changes added extra
excitement not least when alessandro
zanari made way for bruno spengler
during the pit stops the crew had to
adapt the car to the different
requirements of drivers with and without
legs
bmw created special components for
accelerating braking and shifting with
modifications to the pedals and clutch
plus each of the three drivers had
steering wheels adapted to their needs
the engineers also optimized the seat
position and installed air conditioning
conditions are very tricky very
difficult because
you got a dying line
but
if you go out
from that ideal line then
it's literally night and day
sometimes alessandro drives a little on
the wild side yeah a little too too fast
but
what can i do is behind me now
i'm young i need to learn
the three-man team at the wheel were
doing pretty well as they reeled off one
seven kilometer lap after the next
24 hours is the toughest discipline in
motorsports for man machine and the
whole crew
machine
if you look at the team you can see the
total 24 hours of action can take and
the cars too
but then in the final hour cenarity and
his co-drivers had to drop out due to a
technical defect
among the mark vds racing team the mood
was more upbeat marcus portale lucas
lore and nick katzborg were pushing at
the head of the pack in their bmw z4 gt3
and they went on to take the checkered
flag finishing ahead of the two audi
teams wrt and phoenix racing it was the
z4 gt3's first win at the endurance
classic and it's swan song next season
bmw will be competing with the m6 gt3
armies of tradesmen have spent a good
part of their lives in the driver's seat
of the very first generation of the vw
bus called simply the t1
driver christophe bauer is taking one of
the more than 1.8 million t1s built out
for a spin the vw bus was the right
vehicle at the right time
christoph recalls its history starting
in 1947 as west germany was still
rebuilding from the second world war
back then tradespeople urgently needed a
practical utility van to carry their
tools and materials from a to b
despite the massive damage at the vw
plant in wolfsburg a solution was
eventually found
at the time the vw workers were carrying
parts and materials with a transporter
they'd built themselves by putting a
simple flat bed on a beetle chassis and
engine
the parts carrier inspired visiting
dutch vw importer ben pawn to sketch
what would become the vw bus
the engineering was based entirely on
the still new beetle the only vw in
production at the time
kristoff continues and the autumn of
1948 vw chief heinrich nordhoff approved
the construction of a utility van
designed to carry a 750 kilogram payload
based on the dependable vw beetle but it
was not that easy nor cheap as it
happened the beetle chassis tended to
break up under a full load on the poor
quality roads of the time
the beatles platform chassis wasn't
strong enough to handle the one and a
half tons of a fully loaded transporter
so vw's engineers created a new ladder
chassis with a single unit body
the axles engine and many other parts
were still taken from the beetle it was
1950 and all they needed was the right
name
explains that in germany the vw bus is
known as the bully a word combination
from bus and the german word leafabog or
delivery van unfortunately the name was
already trademarked and other
suggestions such as felix jewell mulix
and triumphator were also shot down by
the patent office so what the vw bus was
given the simple designation type 2 but
its german fans didn't care they still
know it as the bully today
the vw bus was a hit with a car buying
public and germany and the world over
and 1954 the one hundred thousandth unit
came off the production line
extra additions like the samba bus and
the practical flatbed pickup soon
appeared
the highly versatile vw bus enjoyed huge
popularity
for kristoff this is one of the
friendliest and most likable faces in
automotive history
these funny big eyes attract lots of
nostalgic looks on the road but the bus
came close to looking quite different
production would have been a great deal
cheaper for a body with square contours
but tests in the wind tunnel showed that
round edges made for much less wind
resistance so the vw bus was in fact one
of the pioneers of aerodynamics
the split front windshield the v-shaped
front panel and a gargantuan vw emblem
gave the first generation of the bus
it's now iconic face
a higher ground clearance and a
practical flatbed with an optional
canvas cover help make the t1 pickup the
ideal construction site workhorse
the double cab was introduced in 1958
with space for six workers and their
tools but heavy loads still pushed the
engine to its limit
and praise of the legendary 1.1 liter
25 horsepower boxer engine taken from
the beetle it's no surprise that a load
of one and a half tons had the engine
puffing and groaning so the engineers
gave it a shorter gear ratio
that brought the top speed down to 80
kilometers per hour but made it more
dependable as a workhorse should be the
1.2 liter engine and this one delivers
34 horsepower
these days the vintage t1 buses are
mostly retired from their labors
with no load they can be surprisingly
nippy even if the maximum speed of just
95 kilometers per hour and the partially
synchronized transmission will keep a
drive in the country very leisurely
kristoff attributes the vw bus's
enormous success to its incredible
versatility the version he's driving now
is a double cab pickup
or as its fans call it adoka
and dokas were the preferred vehicle of
builders the high load silk helps it get
through the rough terrain such as
foundation pits with ease
like all the other additions the double
cab pickup was a best seller and 1958
volkswagen moved production from
wolfsburg to a plant built especially
for commercial vehicles in hanover three
years later the one millionth vw bus
rolled off the assembly line
kristoff says the vw bus is the ultimate
multi-purpose vehicle a workhorse a home
an ambulance a lifestyle mobile the only
limits are the owner's imagination the
aerodynamically optimized body and
lightweight construction left the
competition back for dust it became one
of the driving forces of west germany's
post-war recovery a technology innovator
and without a doubt a milestone in
automotive history definitive and
milestone automobile city
you